[Music]
well good afternoon everybody
I'll come on I got nothing good
afternoon everybody there we go there we
go well thank you so much for spending
your time with me today my name is Dave
Smith I'm a developer advocate here at
Google working on the Android things
platform and I'm here today to talk to
you a little bit about building apps for
the Android things platform and how you
can be more effective in the apps that
you build using the Android SDK so
whether you're new to Android or whether
you've been building Android apps since
the beginning targeting Android things
devices it has some subtle differences
from what you may or may not be used to
in working with the Android
understanding these differences is what
will ensure that you can build better
apps on the platform but Before we jump
into too much of that let me just do a
quick overview of what Android thing's
is maybe for the uninitiated
so Android things is a fully managed
platform for building connected devices
at scale it's a variant of the Android
platform that is optimized for use in
embedded devices it enables you to build
apps for embedded in IOT using the same
Android SDK and Google Play services
that you use to build for the Android
mobile you can develop apps using the
same tools such as Android studio to
deploy and debug your apps to devices as
well it includes the Android things
developer console this is a place where
you can securely manage your software
stability and security updates for your
devices you simply upload your apps
choose the OS version that you want to
run on your device and then deploy those
updates to those devices over-the-air
security updates are even deployed
automatically to those devices for you
Android things also supports powerful
hardware that's suitable for edge
computing and production capable of
driving artificial intelligence and
machine learning out to the edge this
hardware is packaged into system on
modules that make it easy for you to
integrate into your final production
designs so when you look at all these
things together the
this is a little bit different than when
you were building apps on a mobile
device building a typical app for
Android devices means distributing a
single app binary through the Google
Play store typically apps have to work
on multiple devices made by multiple
OEMs targeting multiple versions of the
Android operating system typically
requiring you to do various
compatibility checks and other things
like that to make sure that your app
runs well across that entire breadth of
the ecosystem with Android things your
to the device OEM you control when the
OS on your device gets upgraded and the
various apps that are bundled into that
system image along with it and you do
all of this through the Android things
console instead of through the Google
Play Store this can greatly simplify
your code because you don't need to
incorporate a lot of those same
compatibility checks but there are some
things to consider that are going to be
a little bit different let's start with
displays in Android things displays are
optional they're supported and you can
use the full Android UI toolkit to build
applications that have a graphical user
interface whether it's touch enabled or
not but we've removed a lot of the
default system UI and disabled or
reworked some of the api's that assume
that graphical displays are in place
because many IOT devices will not have
these pieces and we don't want to place
those requirements in there the best
example of this in practice is app
permissions so in Android things
permissions are not granted at runtime
by the end-user because we can't assume
that there's a graphical display to show
things like this dialog and we can't
even really assume that user granting
specific types of permissions is
appropriate for an IOT device so instead
these permissions are actually granted
by you the developer using the Android
things console okay so as the owner of
your device you're responsible for
taking control of the apps that run on
this device and the permissions that
those particular applications have okay
now because of this permissions may not
be granted by
users so that means you don't
necessarily have to check whether or not
those permissions were grant or you
don't have to request for those
permissions to be granted at runtime but
since they are still granted dynamically
the best practice is still for your code
to verify that you have that permission
okay because that permission could have
been revoked by one of the console users
and you don't want your application code
to behave improperly in those cases so
you'll still want to have checks like
this one in your code when you are
accessing dangerous permissions that
could be granted or revoked by the
console but you won't have to include
the code that requests those permissions
up front from the end-user not doing
this will result in the same security
exception that you would otherwise see
by trying to access those protected
permissions if in fact that permission
is disabled additionally in Android
things 1.0 permissions are no longer
granted automatically on reboot this is
something that we did in some of the
earlier previews and is no longer the
case so that means that as a developer
you can't simply just reboot your device
to try and get all those permissions
brought into your app automatically you
have to actually use the tooling to make
that happen
so during development what you're going
to want to do is provide the dash G flag
when installing the applications on your
device and this will grant all the
permissions requested by your app by
default Android studio actually does
this for you automatically so whenever
you click build and run out of the IDE
this process is taken care of for you
but if you want to do this from the
command line you're going to have to add
that flag yourself another option is to
use the PM grant command to individually
grant or revoke promotion permissions
inside of your application you can do
this during development or maybe just to
test what the individual behavior is of
a certain permission if you deny that
inside of your application if you prefer
to use the Gradle command line or
perhaps you're running automated tests
or other things where the IDE is not
involved you can actually add this to
your build.gradle file using an ADB
options block to apply that same
- G flag anytime your application is
installed speaking of UI we should
probably talk a little bit about
activities most developers think that
activities are essentially screens so if
we remove displays why do we need to
keep them around it turns out that
activities are a little bit more than
that an activity represents a component
of user focus in Android for devices
with graphical displays that does mean
that it will render the contents of the
view onto the window but even for
devices without displays activities also
handle all of the user input events
whether that's coming from a touchscreen
input or maybe it's a game controller or
a keyboard or any other external input
device that you may have connected all
of those events are going to be
delivered to the foreground activity so
even without a graphical display
activities are still a very important
portion of Android user interface even
though the user interface might not
actually include the graphical UI
it's important to note also when we're
talking about activities that activities
are still vulnerable to configuration
changes the same way that they are on
Android so as an Android developer
you're probably used to at least at some
point having to deal with an orientation
change of a device and having that
destroy your activity and recreate a new
instance of it that's effectively a very
common configuration change on Android
mobile devices while on android things
that specific instance probably is not
very common if it if it would happen at
all there are still a number of other
configuration changes that might still
happen on Android things devices things
like changing the default locale or
connecting or disconnecting a keyboard a
physical keyboard from the device all of
these events have the same net effect in
that that activity will be destroyed and
recreated if it happens to be in the
foreground so generally speaking with
you're working with activities on
Android things the same rules apply to
activities in terms of the logic that
you put into those components they're
effectively just as fragile in terms of
their life cycle so you're only going to
want to have view based logic
or user interface-based logic inside of
these activities try not to put too much
additional state into these components
you're going to want to push that out
into other parts of your application
Android things even uses activities to
launch your primary application as part
of the boot process we do this using the
home intent which is the same intent
that's used to trigger the app launcher
on an Android mobile device this intent
starts your app automatically on boot
and specifically the activity inside of
that application started automatically
on boot and in addition to that if that
application crashes or terminates for
any reason Android is going to restart
that application automatically so this
becomes the the main entry point into
your application that is automatically
managed by the Android things platform
so we don't want to forget about
activities just yet a couple other
things about Android things devices
Android things devices are also
relatively memory constrained when you
compare them to an Android phone a
typical Android things device may have
512 megabytes of RAM or so compare that
with the multiple gigabytes of RAM that
you would have on an Android phone like
say a pixel or a pixel - what this
translates to for you the developer is
that there's actually a much lower per
process heap size for your individual
application so if you're not familiar
with this idea Android sets a fixed heap
level on every application running on
that device and it's significantly lower
than the total available memory on that
device and since the Android thinks
devices are relatively memory
constrained that per process limit is
significantly lower than it would be on
an Android phone because of that if
you're porting code from an Android
mobile device over to Android things you
just have to realize that if you're
using the same amount of memory in your
app there's going to be a lot less free
memory in that same process available to
you okay so you have to keep that in
mind and you also want to realize that
this can also translate into a
significantly larger amount of garbage
collection events
happening as you allocate new objects
okay so you want to keep a close eye on
object allocations how often you're
doing object allocations because you may
run into that ceiling much more quickly
than you otherwise would on an Android
device or you might see the garbage
collector kicking in quite a bit more
the memory profiler in Android studio is
a really great resource to help you keep
an eye on what's going on inside your
memory it will allow you to track those
allocations over time as well as see
overlaid into it the individual garbage
collection events so you can get a
really good idea of whether or not your
application is allocating too much
memory and causing trouble some of the
things that you can do to help
understand your device a little bit
better is use some of the activity
manager methods to do some inspection on
the memory capabilities of your
particular device so for example you can
use the memory class attribute on
activity manager this will give you the
exact heap size that's available to your
application the value is returned as a
value in megabytes that is how much
memory you have the large memory class
attribute is what your application would
have if you added the large heap
attribute to your manifest I would
caution you against doing this on
android things generally speaking
because Android things devices are
memory constrained the memory class and
the large memory class of these devices
are generally configured to be the same
value so adding this attribute to your
manifest is essentially not going to do
anything okay you also want to inspect
the low memory threshold of this device
to get a sense for what that actually
looks like when the available memory on
the device falls below that memory
threshold the device is in a state that
we call memory pressure and we're gonna
talk a little bit more about what that
means and why it's important in a little
bit but just keep it in mind for now so
I want you to notice something else
about this diagram that I had up before
because of this per process heap limit
that's a fixed value for a single
application if you try to put all of
your application code into a single
process or a single apk you're going to
be severely limited in yoruba
to fully utilize the memory that is
available on this device okay now keep
in mind with Android things the only
apps on the device are your apps so you
should be able to take full advantage of
those memory resources as much as you
possibly can the way to do that is to
split your application into multiple
processes okay because that limit
essentially will apply to each one of
those processes individually so if you
Confederate the design of your
application out into multiple components
that are actually running in separate
apks you're gonna have a much better
ability to fully utilize the memory
available on whatever device that you're
running to make the most effective use
of our device we're gonna break this app
up into multiple apks with the primary
activity running in the foreground and
additional apps running in the
background you with support services
running inside the additional benefit of
running this architecture is that it
actually insulates these various
components from one another so in this
scenario if a crash happens in one of
these components it's localized just to
that element and it won't bring down
your entire application and half you
have to restart all of that from the
beginning so you can manage those
individual issues just within that
component and leave the rest of the
applications or components running on
your device to be unaffected it also
means that you can launch or relaunch
these components individually as needed
by your application so if you don't need
to load everything at once at boot you
can launch the various services and
components just as you need them now it
turns out the decision to put some of
your components into background apps has
consequences as well
Android treats foreground and background
processes a little bit differently and
we need to be aware of what's going on
under the hood here Android marks
application processes by priority based
on how closely they are related to the
foreground application and this is very
important because of a system process
known as the low memory killer the low
memory killer
is a process that is constantly prowling
in the background looking for new
processes to devour its job is to ensure
that the free memory on the system is
available to the foreground app at any
given time so if the foreground app
needs new memory and the device happens
to be in a system of memory pressure low
memory killer is going to go hunting
around for processes that it can
terminate to allocate that memory back
to the foreground okay
on an Android device like a typical user
driven Android device this can be
somewhat of a nuisance to developers
because their app may get terminated
from the background but at some point
the users gonna relaunch it later and
everything will be fine on Android
things the low memory killer could mean
that you have critical device
functionality that is being terminated
out from under heat underneath you and
you didn't even know it perhaps there's
a device driver running in that service
and Android killed that because it
thought it was low enough priority in
the background okay so something to keep
in mind as you're moving through this in
addition Android Orio introduced
execution limits for background apps so
applications can no longer be started
into a background state they must either
be launched from the foreground app or
bound to it in some way so because of
these two things there's a number of
different common ways that you may or
may not have used in the past
to launch components into the background
okay we're gonna kind of walk through
those a little bit so the first that you
might be familiar with is using the boot
completed broadcast to listen for a
final boot message coming from the
android framework saying that the system
is up and running you can launch other
apps if you would like do not use this
on Android things the primary reason is
because of those background execution
limits your background services actually
can't be properly started into that
state in a lot of cases it won't even
work okay and in addition to that this
background broadcast this boot completed
broadcast is very unpredictable in terms
of its timing in a lot of cases this
boot completed broadcast actually
triggers much much later than when the
home in ten
in the home activity are fully up and
running in the foreground okay so if
you're trying to synchronize between
these two things it's not a very good
mechanism to rely on in addition I would
recommend you don't use start service
for a similar reason start service is
limited by those same background
execution
limits unless you are starting a service
in foreground mode now foreground
services require you as a developer to
actually build in a notification that
would typically display to the user when
that service is running well we took
away the system UI where that
notification would display so you're
ended up doing a bunch of work for
displaying the service that it doesn't
actually gain you anything and in
addition to that there are some
difficulties with started services when
it comes to managing their lifecycle a
started service if you crash if that
crashes for some reason you don't have a
direct connection to understand that
that occurred and that you need to
restart that service so that you can
manage that process a little bit better
now Android does have this thing that
services can return this start sticky
attribute and that's a way for
applications to tell Android that this
service is important and if it crashes
or terminates for some reason I need it
to be restarted
however Android usually only does this
about once or twice for a given service
before they just sort of give up and
realize that at some point the user will
launch this app again maybe this will
start again and everything will be fine
okay that type of thinking doesn't go
well for those background services that
have critical functionality in them like
it like a device driver okay so we
recommend you use buying service instead
by using bound services this gives the
background process is an active
connection to that foreground app okay
so you'll have a you have a good
indication of when that service is
running and when that service has died
for some reason so that you can manage
that relaunch it if you need to do any
of those things this also has the added
benefit of a built-in communication
channel between the applications that
are bound so you can do some more direct
communication with that service without
having to use intense or other
mechanisms like that to pass
data back and forth so looking at this
diagram again one of the other important
reasons to use bound services is that
pure background applications like those
that would have been started by boot
completed or just start service on its
own are very low priority on the scale
okay
whereas bound service applications are
almost as high priority as the
foreground app they are literally the
highest priority you can get without
being the foreground app so this ensures
that those background processes stay
safe from something like low memory
killer
if the device ever does get into a
memory pressure situation okay
so you get better management of those
services and you get better protection
from a memory management perspective
alright let's take a look at what this
would actually look like in code so if I
have a just a basic example of a service
here that has a device driver inside of
it in this case this is just a device
driver to take some button inputs and
convert them into key events like they
were coming off of a keyboard all of
this logic can be fully encapsulated
into this external service and can run
on its own so we can build this service
component and then from the foreground
app we can construct an intent to that
service component and we can bind to it
notice that I'm doing this from the
application class and not from the
primary activity remember our discussion
from activities before and the lifecycle
associated with those if this is a
service that needs to be as persistent
as possible we want to bind to it from a
component that it's is expected to be
around just as long okay so that you
don't end up with life cycle issues
where your activity gets destroyed
recreated and your rebinding to that
service unnecessarily
doesn't necessarily cause a major
problem but it's not the best idea in
addition with bound services this also
means that you get this feedback
mechanism coming through the service
connection callback so when you bind to
a service you provide this callback as a
service connection and when the service
is up and running you will be notified
through the on service connected method
so you know exactly when this is now
something you can interact with or
communicate with if you need to
in addition on service disconnected
tells us anytime that service stops
unexpectedly maybe because it is crashed
or something else has occurred and at
that point we probably need to take a
look at restarting this especially if
it's running some critical functionality
on our device so we now have the
information we need to properly manage
this functionality from within our
applications which we wouldn't get with
started services or other of these more
independent mechanisms so here's kind of
a final picture of that architecture
again Android is going to manage for us
automatically that foreground app using
the home intent it will launch it
automatically on boot and it will
relaunch it if that application crashes
for any reason and then our application
code can then manage these additional
background support services through the
Bound Service mechanism alright the last
thing that I want to share with you
today are just a couple of quick tips on
doing this type of development from
within Android studio or within the
development tools so you can manage
multiple apks from within a single
Android studio project by adding each
additional package as a new module you
can add multiple modules to the same
project and all of those modules can
represent an apk or an individual app
process this allows you to manage all of
your code in one place even though
they're technically separate apps now by
default Android studio does not allow
you to deploy an app module that does
not contain a launcher activity okay or
an activity that has that main launcher
intent filter on it this doesn't work so
well for background service apps that
don't have any activities at all in them
in some cases but you can modify this
behavior for a background services app
you can edit the run configuration and
simply adjust the launch options for
that particular module set that target
to nothing instead of default activity
this will enable Android studio to
deploy that service only app to your
device and it won't complain
you can also do this from the command
line and one of the advantages of doing
it this way is that Android studio does
require that it you deploy only one
module at a time by selecting that
module from the run configuration list
in the UI so if you have an application
that's constructed of four or five
different modules all as individual apks
it can be a bit cumbersome if you have
to try and deploy them all individually
all the time one of the advantages of
using the Gradle command line is that by
default when you run a command like
install debug with no other modifiers it
builds and installs every module in that
project so with one command you can
deploy everything on the latest version
to that device and you can still do
individual modules if you would prefer
to do that by just adding the module
name to the command as well once you've
got the modules on the device the other
thing you can do directly from the
command line that isn't really supported
in Android studio today is the ability
to start those individual components
whether they're activities or services
so using the am shell commands you can
trigger those services manually if you
want to test out some of that behavior
sort of independently from the rest of
the system even though they may be
managed by the foreground app in
production all right so let's quickly
review some of the tips that we've gone
through here today don't assume a
graphical UI designed for your memory
constraints on these devices break your
app up into modules bind your background
services to the foreground app don't use
started services and use the Gradle
command line if you want to have more
control over deploying your modules to
the device now if you're just as excited
about Android things as we are I want to
remind everyone that we're doing a
scavenger hunt here at Google i/o if you
visit the link here or use the Google
i/o app you can follow the instructions
to find various items around the
conference and once you've created or
once you've completed those challenges
you can then receive a free Android
things developer kit to take home to
learn more about Android things visit
the developer site and make sure to
visit the code labs office hours
other demos that we have here in the
sandbox also be sure to visit Android
things with Google comm to find featured
community projects and additional sample
code you'll also find a lot of the
sample code available for some of the
demos that we have here the conference
on Android things with Google comm as
well so thank you everyone for your time
today and I'm really excited to see the
apps that you build with Android things
[Music]